studious oh yeah gotta eat you [ __ ]
it's gonna be so [ __ ] hard oh my god
oh god I gotta screen a bug where your
eyes loaded just like I'm coming for
that ass hey hey don't attack me I'm
eating birds now shame on you I have a
friend I have a friend okay you wanna
[ __ ] with me [ __ ] with my flames my guy
not doing [ __ ] I'm just jumping around
like a [ __ ] idiot
dead we get them I'll fire the wife
[ __ ] look dead [ __ ]
oh this [ __ ] sucks all right
worst case that was really fun I really
enjoy jumping around while you oh how do
I'm running for it
[ __ ] this Raina's the monster like
really gets your heart going you get so
yeah mind you yeah yeah totally I felt
that too great
what oh yeah you're the monster alright
so Felix once you load in just start
running away and killing little
creatures yeah
where the [ __ ] is away anywhere but
where you start because where you start
is right near where we're gonna drop in
I don't understand why the monster runs
like Jesus Christ I'm such a [ __ ] ball
Felix can't just hang out and have fun
he's gonna attack it Oh God uh-oh what's
happening I'm pretty stage two whoa Jake
Jake Jake don't die Oh No Hey
let's just spectate Jack I'm taking him
guys shooting my skinny [ __ ] tank
you're a [ __ ] boss [ __ ] American
ways [ __ ] American [ __ ] I'm
shooting this beautiful anus you got so
many babies left we could eat a little
bit of eggs come on yeah come on let us
eat your babies [ __ ] you and your babies
wait why don't you get you where you
wanna be right you wanna kill them
I'm [ __ ] killing Daisy again okay
where's Daisy I'll shield Daisy Daisy
Daisy there's Daisy
I'm shielding Daisy don't give a [ __ ] oh
god he's here with his baby [ __ ] is baby
yeah oh the Martin I'm dead shoot him in
the day job what the frog was reading me
your little baby beat my ass doing
[ __ ] idiot
I wonder how it looks like Daisy jumping
out of that [ __ ] there's Daisy Daisy you
crazy what you guys doing can we just
you guys are very rude let's just watch
one on one Ken versus Felix
[ __ ] [ __ ] Slam Duggan hell
[ __ ]
all right so we have 1v1 again is that
what it was
hey what you want some use your
abilities thanks for that tip idiot Jack
Levin one-on-one it's too easy really so
bad oh really
come again you scrub scrub hit me okay
jack head he's our man he's not trying
to hit me Oh Daisy saved me [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] Daisy that's right [ __ ] you up [ __ ]
is Daisy doing alive [ __ ] you Daisy I
don't hate you Daisy
[ __ ] you Daisy what are you going Daisy
I mean he's actually lived around me one
day she's going this way let's follow
Daisy yeah track oh oh he's here
Daisy found out that Felix turn around
turn around right now I'm not gonna do
it easy where's Daisy
where's think you see what I mean
can I get a healer oh I am getting fun
okay I'm a giant monster hello darkness
my old friend
margarines shut up you son of a [ __ ]
I'll pocket Kalia paired dear dear don't
worry she's fine she's fine